pau
[Musique]
propriétaire de 349 site le département
gère un patrimoine architectural
exceptionnel des gîtes de montagne au
musée historique
ces équipements sont au coeur des
actions de valorisation portée par la
collectivité
la première consiste à faire de ces
sites un levier de développement
économique
pour ce faire nous avons entamé donc
différents chantiers 1 à savoir de la
réhabilitation des gîtes puisque l'année
dernière ce sont pas loin de 5 j qui ont
été réhabilités
donc nous avons souhaité effectivement
donné
aux régions j'allais dire reculé de
notre île leurs lettres de noblesse et
il ya également donc la volonté de
pouvoir donner une dimension économique
à certains sites emblématiques je pense
au golf de l'étang salé qui va
accueillir dans un hôtel cinq étoiles en
2020 un hôtel cinq étoiles donc il
pourra donc permettre à la fois aux
touristes et bien de pouvoir jouir d'un
complexe golfique ce internationale avec
trois restaurants un spa et là on a
réellement effectivement une vision
globale sur ce site emblématique qui
consiste réellement et bien donc à
pouvoir optimiser nos sites
départementaux
chaque année le département alou 3
millions d'euros pour l'entretien de ses
77 collège de nouveaux établissements
verront le jour à saint paul et à la
plaine des palmistes
le service patrimoine de la collectivité
souhaite dans ses actions de
valorisation placer l'humain au coeur de
ses services pour ce faire nous avons
engagé un grand chantier qui touche à la
modernisation territoriales l'intérêt
j'allais dire principal est de créer ce
qu'on appelle des circuits raccourci à
guichet unique la maison départementale
du port on est l'exemple concret où vous
allez retrouver dans un seul et même
bâtiment un service dédié à l'enfance un
service insertion
un service qui touche effectivement donc
au loyer modéré pour pouvoir permettre
aux administrés aux réunionnais en
général et bien de pouvoir prendre la
pleine mesure de l'accompagnateur social
que nous sommes en mettant à sa
disposition des services de proximité
l'accessibilité est aussi un enjeu
majeur porté par la collectivité
sur les 186 établissements recevant du
public
78 millions d'euros seront investis sur
9 ans afin de rendre ces services
complètement accessible aux porteurs de
handicap
[Musique]